[Musik]
er war die Schlüsselperson der US-
Außenpolitik in der zweiten Hälfte des
20 Jahrhunderts erst als nationaler
Sicherheitsberater und dann als
Außenminister unter Richard Nixon galt
Henry Kissinger Jahre lang als das
öffentliche Gesicht der sogenannten
Realpolitik die angeblich Pragmatismus
über alles stellt von den einen geliebt
von den anderen angefeeindet prägten
seine Entscheidungen nicht nur die
Außenpolitik der USA sondern auch die
Welt wie wir sie heute kennen Kissinger
war einer der großen Architekten der
Öffnung der Beziehungen zwischen den USA
und der Volksrepublik China des Endes
des Vietnamkriegs und der Aufnahme von
Friedensverhandlungen zwischen Israel
und Ägypten ein Prozess der Jahre später
im Abkommen von Camp David gipfelte dem
ersten großen Friedensabkommen zwischen
Israel und einem arabischen Land und am
29 November 2023 ist Henry Kissinger im
gesegneten Alter von 100 Jahren
gestorben bis zuletzt war der aus
Franken stammende deutschamerikaner
jedoch politisch und medial aktiv hat
sich in vielen aktuellen Belangen der
Geopolitik engagiert und hochgradig
polarisiert Henry Kissinger ist gestern
gestorben in den nächsten Tagen wird
viel über ihn diskutiert werden ich
gehöre zu denen die er nicht beeindruckt
hat seine Fähigkeiten scheinen ein
Ergebnis jener PR Maschinerie zu sein
die ständig versucht die Menschen davon
zu überzeugen dass diejenigen die an der
Macht sind genisee sein und wüssten was
sie tun was oft nicht der Fall ist
allerdings hat es Kissinger geschafft
seine weitgehend gescheiterte Amtszeit
als Außenminister in eine Karriere als
unglaublich gut bezahlter Lobbyist
umzumünzen Philips P O'Brien Professor
für strategische Studien an der St
Andrews University aber unabhängig von
unserer persönlichen Meinung über
Kissinger war er zweifellos einer der
großen Akteure in der internationalen
Politik des 20 Jahrhunderts ohne ihn
sehe die Welt von heute ganz anders aus
vielleicht besser oder vielleicht
schlechter aber auf jeden Fall ganz
anders das und deshalb wollen wir in
diesem Video ein paar brisante Fragen
über diesen Kontroversen Menschen
beantworten wer genau war Henry
Kissinger wirklich und welche Bedeutung
hatte er für das Machtgleichgewicht im
Kalten Krieg auf welche Weise hat er
unsere Welt geformt was waren seine
großen Erfolge und was seine großen
Fehler und auf welche Weise mischte er
bis zuletzt mit in diesem Video werden
wir all diese Fragen beantworten lasst
uns aber vorher noch unserem Sponsor in
cogni danken der das heutige Video erst
möglich gemacht hat ein Sponsor der euch
zu dem aktiv vor Datenmissbrauch durch
sogenannte databoker schützen kann
databoker sind datenmakler die unsere
persönlichen Daten überall im Netz
abgreifen und danach nicht nur an
seriöse Unternehmen verkaufen sondern
auch an Betrüger diese Betrüger
bombardieren uns dann mit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-Mails oder versuchen
uns sogar auszunehmen Nachteile durch
die Verbreitung deiner Daten müssen dir
aber gar nicht erst durch betrügeer
erwachsen hast du dir schon mal überlegt
wer alles aus deinen Daten Rückschlüsse
ziehen könnte teilweise sind diese ja
sogar falsch bzw verfälscht oder können
eine viel Interpretation deines
Verhaltens im Netz darstellen tja und
dann wunderst du dich warum du z.B vom
neuen Arbeitgeber oder Vermieter
abgelehnt wirst plötzlich höhere
Versicherungsbeiträge zahlen musst oder
kein Kredit von der Bank bekommst und
zwar ohne jeden wahren Grund dafür zu
erfahren ganz genau leider haben wir
keinerlei Kontrolle darüber an wen alles
die databroker unsere Daten verkaufen
und was Ihre Kunden dann daraus gegen
uns stricken aber es gibt zum Grund
einen Ausweg aus diesem Albtraum die
databroker sind nämlich gesetzlich dazu
verpflichtet unsere Daten zu löschen
wenn wir sie dazu auffordern das Problem
dabei es gibt Tausende von ihnen oft ist
der Antragsprozess absichtlich
kompliziert gestaltet deswegen
resignieren viele Menschen einfach und
lassen den ganzen schmo passiv über sich
ergehen der Sponsor dieses Videos
incogni bietet jedoch genau hierf eine
Lösung incogni übernimmt nämlich die
Aufgabe bei den datab Brokern
aufzuräumen die Löschanträge zu stellen
und sie gegebenfalls juristisch
durchzusetzen du meldest dich einfach
bei incogni an beauftragst sie in deinem
Namen die Löschanträge durchzusetzen und
verfolgst dann bequem auf einem
übersichtlichen Dashboard wie deine
Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden ohne einen solchen Service
wäre es be ein normalen Menschen nahzu
unmöglich diese Löschanträge selbst zu
bearbeiten und sich vor Betrug zu
schützen also du was gutes für deine
datenhygiene und schau dir incogni über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung an
außerdem über den Promocode politik.de
hältst du auch noch 60% Rabatt wenn du
zu den ersten 100 gehörst die ihn nutzen
so und nun lasst uns über den großen
Teich ins Amerika des Kalten Krieges
reisen um der Macht Henry Kissingers auf
den Grund zu gehen
aufgepasst
[Musik]
wir schreiben das Jahr
1969 die USA hten mehr als 26 000
Atomwaffen in ihrem Arsenal tausende
Militärbasen in ganz Europa und
zahlreiche flotten auf den Weltmeeren
alles ist bereit für den Kampf gegen das
rote Reich des Bösen der Kalte Krieg hat
zwar seine schwierigsten Jahre hinter
sich aber die Welt war zu dieser der
Zeit ein verdammt gefährlicher Ort und
wir reden hier nicht nur über ein
mögliches nukleares Armageddon so gab es
den Konflikt zwischen Indien und
Pakistan das wachsende Chaos in
Lateinamerika die Entkolonialisierung
Afrikas und den arabisch-israelischen
Konflikt neben vielen anderen außerdem
führte der Sturz von Nikita kruschow in
der Sowjetunion im Jahr 1964 und seine
Ablösung durch Leonid breschnev zu einer
Rückkehr zu einer harten Linie und ein
Unterbrechung der Entspannungspolitik im
Grunde könnte man sagen dass die Welt zu
einem riesigen Pulverfass geworden war
jer Funke konnte sie in tausend Stücke
sprengen dies galt es natürlich zu
vermeiden es war Zeit auf die Bremse zu
treten und die Spannung abzubauen aber
die Frage war wie verdammt noch mal nun
im November 1968 gewann der Republikaner
Richard Nixon die Präsidentschaftswahlen
es lag nun an ihm den neuen
amerikanischen Führer für die
internationale Politik zu wählen und das
meine Liebens Zuschauer war der Beginn
der ERA Kissinger aber eins nach dem
anderen
der Mann den wir alle als Henry
Kissinger kennen wurde eigentlich als
Heinz Alfred Kissinger am 27 mai 1923 im
mittelfränkischen fürt geboren n 10
Jahre bevor die Nazis an die Macht kamen
seine Familie war deutschjüdisch und als
Adolf Hitler 1933 an die Macht kam
sollte sich ihr Leben für immer
verändern die segregationsmaßnahmen der
Nazis verdrängten sie nach und nach aus
dem zivilen Leben bis es seiner Familie
schließlich 1938 als Kissinger gerade
mal 15 Jahre alt war gelang aus deland
zu fliehen zunächst nach Großbritannien
dann in die
USA genauer gesagt nach New York wo er
sich am City College Einschreiben sollte
um Buchhaltung zu studieren im Laufe der
Zeit erwarb er 1943 die
US-Staatsbürgerschaft und wurde noch im
selben Jahr rekrutiert und an die
europäische Front geschickt dort landete
er dank seiner deutschen
Sprachkenntnisse und seines fränkischen
Akzents als Kommandeur der
Spionageabwehr im Kreis Bergstraße in
Hessen und wenn ihr so darüber nachdenkt
war das schon eine ziemlich
überraschende Wendung der Ereignisse
oder Kissinger der mit seiner Familie
als Verfolgter Jude aus Deutschland
geflohen war kehrte als US-Bürger in
sein Heimatland zurück um einen offenen
Krieg gegen das nazegime zu führen tja
das Leben ist voller Wendungen doch das
Schlimmste sollte noch
kommen als Kissinger nämlich in die USA
zurückkehrte hatte sich etwas in ihm
verändert er wollte nicht mehr
Buchhaltung studieren er erkannte dass
ein ganzes Leben von politischen
Entscheidungen ge gewesen war und nun
war seine Leidenschaft für diese
Tätigkeit unwiderruflich entfacht und
wie wir hier so schön sagen gesagt getan
im Jahr 1950 schloss er sein Studium der
Politikwissenschaften an an der Harvard
University mit Auszeichnung ab und ein
paar Jahre später promovierte er an der
gleichen Elite
[Musik]
Hochschule auf diese Weise wurde er nach
und nach in die Kreise aufgenommen die
die internationale Politik des Landes
bestimmten Kissinger arbeitete für den
Council on Foreign Relations das
Außenministerium und die rent
Corporation einen einflussreichen
politischen Think Tank die Rolle die ihn
allerdings einen entscheidenden Schritt
näher an die Macht bringen sollte war
das Angebot als außenpolitischer Berater
für die präsidentschaftskampagnen von
Nelson Rockefeller zu arbeiten den
damaligen Gouverneur von New York und
Gegner von Richard Nixon bei den
Vorwahlen der Republikaner Kissinger
positionierte sich also vor den Toren
der macht aber noch war er nicht
drinnen eine Welt in
[Musik]
Flammen am 5 November 1968 gewann
Richard millhus Nixen die
Präsidentschaftswahlen und wurde der 37
Präsident der USA in einer Welt die
alles andere als friedlich und ruhig war
und nein ich übertreibe kein bisschen
wenn der Krieg in der Ukraine heute wie
ein Konflikt aussieht der die
internationale Ordnung in ihren
Grundfesten erschüttern kann dann stellt
euch nur einmal vor wie die Situation
Ende der 1960er Jahre war die USA hatten
bereits fast 17 000 Soldaten in Vietnam
verloren die Sowjetunion hatte
beschlossen in die Tschechoslowakei
einzumarschieren und der Nahe Osten war
nach dem sech tagekrieg und dem triumphf
des ägyptischen Nationalismus ein
Pulverfass und lasst uns nicht vergessen
dass es zur gleichen Zeit abertausende
von Atomsprengköpfen gab die die Welt
innerhalb weniger Minuten vaporisieren
konnten als ob das nicht schon genug
wäre sollten die Ermordung von Präsident
Kennedy die
antivetnamkriegsbewegung und der
endgültige Kampf gegen die
Rassentrennung für starke Spannungen in
der amerikanischen Gesellschaft das war
die Situation mit der der neue
republikanische präsident Richard Nixon
konfrontiert war meine Lieben
[Musik]
Zuschauer nach seinem Wahlsieg lut Nixon
Kissinger in sein New Yorker Büro ein um
ihn besser kennenzulernen das Treffen
muss ja gut gelaufen sein denn nur
wenige Wochen später bot Nixon Kissinger
nichts Geringeres als den Posten des
nationalen Sicherheitsberaters an das
ist der zweithöchste Kabinettsposten der
nicht vom Senat bestätigt werden musste
der Höchste ist der des
Stabschefs
aber die Erwartung die Kissinger in
Nixon geweckt hatte schien nicht
erwidert zu
werden ich bin durch mit der Politik der
Republikaner die Partei ist hoffnungslos
und regierungsunfähig an drei Tagen in
der Woche denke ich dass ich für Hubert
humfrey den demokratischen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten stimmen werde
an den anderen Tagen dass ich wohl gar
nicht wählen werde Henry Kissinger im
August
1968 um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu
geben was ein ehemaliger Chef gvern
Nelson Rockefeller unseren Protagonisten
erzählen musste er tadelte mich dafür
dass ich meine Entscheidung aufgeschoben
hatte und forderte mich auf nens Angebot
sofort anzunehmen wenn dich der
Präsident zu einem wichtigen Dienst
einledädt so merkte er an seit zögern
keine angemessene Reaktion vergiss nicht
fügte rockerfeller an dass Nixon mit dir
ein viel größeres Risiko eingeht als du
mit ihm am selben Nachmittag rief ich
Nixon an Henry Kissinger in seinem Buch
leadership six studies in global
strategy so nun hatte Kissinger seinen
Platz an der Spit der macht doch hier
fängt unsere Geschichte eigentlich erst
richtig an hört gut
zu mit den
despotenkuscheln im August 1968 mitten
im US-Wahlkampf ordnete leonig preschnev
eine Militärintervention in der
Tschechoslowakei an dort hatte die
Regierung des gemäßigten Kommunisten
Alexander duupsek ein Paket von Reformen
zur wirtschaftlichen und politischen
Liberalisierung des Landes gekündigt und
der Kremmel war nicht damit
einverstanden dass ein Mitglied des
Warschauer Paktes der Art aus der Reihe
tanzt zu dieser Zeit durchlief die
kommunistische Supermacht das was
Washington die bresnwsche Stagnation
nannte die sowjetische Wirtschaft hatte
begonnen erste größere Risse zu zeigen
und konnte nicht mehr mit den USA
mithalten und trotz des Einmarsches in
die Tschechoslowakei war Kissinger der
Meinung dass dies der perfekte Moment
war um eine Annäherung zu fördern seine
Theorie war dass die USA nicht versuchen
sollten die Probleme des ins Straucheln
geratenen sowjetimerium auszunutzen um
die Machthaber im Kremmel in die Enge zu
treiben stattdessen wollte er den Moment
nutzen um kleine Veränderungen
herbeizuführen bereits da zeigten sich
bei Kissinger also erste Anzeichen einer
gewissen Nachgiebigkeit gegenüber den
Russen die sich in seinen späteren
Lebensjahren noch in rein rassiger
appeasementpitik manifestieren sollten
Kissingers sanfte Schritte umfassten den
Besuch des ehemaligen Führers des
kommunistischen Rumäniens Nicol chesco
in Washington im Jahr 1969 und nächstens
anschließende Besuche in Jugoslawien und
auch in Moskau und die Wahrheit ist dass
diese Strategie bis zu einem gewissen
Grad funktioniert hat die Beziehungen
verbesserten sich und 1971 wurde der
svertrag unterzeichnet um das
Atomwaffenarsenal beider Mächte zu
begrenzen anderseit betontik das
Kissinger den Sowjets damit Luft zum
Atmen gegeben
[Musik]
habe eine Verschnaufpause die erst
Ronald Dragon über 10 Jahre später mit
seiner unnachgebigkeit beendet hat was
dann ja auch zum Zusammenbruch des
sowjetimeriums führte und den besetzten
Völkern Mittel- und Osteuropas die
ersehnte Freiheit brachte viele sprechen
daher von mindestens einem verlorenen
jahrzeht das auf das Konto Kissingers
geht aber natürlich war der Kalte Krieg
nicht das einzige Problem Washingtons zu
diesen gehörten ja schließlich so einige
heiße Stellvertreterkriege und zu dieser
Zeit entwickelte sich der Vietnamkrieg
bereits zu einem altbtraum ein
nichtenden wollender immer teurerer und
unpopulärer Krieg es war klar dass die
USA einen Ausweg finden mussten aber
welchen vergesst bitte nicht als Nixon
als Präsident beereidigt wurde hatten
die USA mehr als 500.000 Soldaten in
Vietnam stationiert die amerikanische
Gesellschaft lehnte dies aber zum
Großteil ab es handelte sich um eine
politisch unhaltbare Situation auch wenn
ein militärischer Sieg eventuell möglich
gewesen wäre und deshalb hat der neue
Präsident sein Kabinett beauftragt das
Ende des Krieges und den Abzug der
Truppen noch während der ersten amszeit
herbeizuführen ihr wisst ja er konnte
nicht zulassen dass eine Kleinigkeit wie
ein lästiger Krieg um die Freiheit der
Vietnamesen seiner Wiederwahl im Wege
stehen würde 1973 stand der Konflikt
schließlich kurz vor seinem Ende etwas
für das der vietnamesische revolutionär
leduk Thor und Henry Kissinger den
Friedensnobelpreis erhielten obwohl
Kissinger ihn nicht annahm weil er der
Meinung war dass der Konflikt noch and
die Vergabe des Friedensnobelpreises an
Kissinger eine noch größere Fars war als
die an Barack Obama muss man wissen was
bereits vor der Wahl nächstens zum
Präsidenten hinter den Kulissen
abgelaufen war erinnert ihr euch noch
daran wie ich gesagt habe dass Kissinger
vor nixens Wahl von ihm und seiner
Politik gerade zu angewieddert war nun
damals arbeitete er bereits als
inoffizieller Berater der amerikanischen
Delegation bei den Pariser
Friedensgesprächen zwischen den
Vietnamesen und der Regierung des
Demokraten Johnson da die Chancen für
Nixen nächster Präsident zu werden
jedoch recht gut standen bot kissenger
zur gleichen Zeit nstens Team Insider
Information über den Verlauf der
Verhandlungen an damit dieser sie im
Wahlkampf für sich nutzen konnte im
Gegenzug verlangte kissenger die
Garantie dass Nixon ihn nach einem
eventuellen Wahlsieg in sein Team
aufnimmt tja das passierte dann ja auch
die Regierungspartei wechselte aber
Kissinger blieb und viele Jahre später
kam heraus dass Nixon Johnsons
Friedensgespräche gezielt sabotieren
wollte um dann später die lorbären
selbst einstreichen zu können dass er
den Krieg beendet hat daher gibt es
Stimmen die behaupten Nixon und
kissenger seien eigentlich dafür
verantwortlich dass der Krieg viele
Jahre länger gedauert hätte allerdings
ist nicht wirklich klar ob ihr Einfluss
hierzu 1968 schon groß genug war aber
erst 195 mit dem Fall von Saigon fand
dieses militärische und politische
disaster für die USA 20 Jahre nach
seinem Beginn ein füror allem mal ein
Ende und sieehe da seine Bemühungen um
ein politisches Tauwetter mit der
Sowjetunion und seine Rolle beim
Zustandekommen des Kriegsendes brachten
Kissinger eine Beförderung ein und was
für eine Beförderung ohne seinen Posten
als nationaler Sicherheitsberater
aufgeben zu müssen gab Nixen ihm auch
den Posten des Außenministers und so
wurde Henry Kissinger zu einer der
mächtigsten Figuren in der gesamten
Geschichte der internationalen Politik
der USA nur wenige Menschen haben je so
viel Gewicht in einem Kabinett angehäuft
und der neue Rockstar der amerikanischen
internationalen Politik nutzte dies um
das einzusetzen was heute als
pendeldiplomatie bekannt ist oder auch
als dreiecksdiplomatie das heißt die
Annährung zweier verfeindeter Länder
durch die Intervention eines Dritten
Akteurs der beiden Parteien freundlich
gesind ist genau das war die Strategie
die kissenger im Nahen Osten
verfolgte 1973 war nämlich ein sehr
bewegtes Jahr für die ganze Welt es war
das Jahr des yomkipurkriegs in dem
Ägypten und Syrien Israel überfielen
Kissinger nutzte seine Art von
Dreiecksbeziehungen um als Vermittler
zwischen der israelischen
Regierungschefin goldameire und dem
ägyptischen Präsidenten Anwar el sandat
aufzutreten und nicht nur das der neue
Leiter der US-Außenpolitik lud auch die
Sowjetunion zu der Verhandlungsrunde ein
denn die Russen unterstützten die damals
den totalitaristischen Sozialismus
zugeneigten Araber in ihrem Kreuzzug
gegen die freiheitlich orientierten
Israelis kissenger brachte sogar die
Möglichkeit ins Spiel eine UN-Truppe aus
beiden Supermächten zu bilden um die
Region um den suiskanal zu befrieden die
Idee kam nicht zustande aber ich meine
US-amerikanische und sowjetische Truppen
seit an seit der Typ hatte schon eine
blühende Fantasie die nicht gerade ein
Zeichen realistischer Urteilsfähigkeit
war tatsache ist jedoch dass der
jomkipur Konflikt nach 19 Tagen beendet
war und die von kistenser geförderte
Ernährung zwischen Israel und Ägypten
nicht nur zu einem Waffenstillstand
führte nein sie gipfelte in Sadats
Besuch in Israel Ende 1977 und im Jahr
drauf unter der Regierung kter im Camp
David Abkommen also erinnern wir uns in
nur vier Jahren hatte Kissinger den
Abzug aus Vietnam eine historische
Annäherung an die Sowjetunion ein
bedeutendes atomabkommen und zu allem
Überfluss ein Waffenstillstand im
pulverfassener Ost erreicht kein
schlechtes Ergebnis für eine so kurz
Amtszeit nicht war und trotzdem sollte
seine größte Leistung das Werk dass die
Welt wahrscheinlich mehr als jedes
andere verändert hat erst noch kommen
die Rede ist natürlich von China ein
epochenwandel der erst jene Welt
hervorgebracht hat in der wir heute
leben und ja auch diesen hat maßgeblich
Henry Kissinger mit gestaltet haltet
euch
fest China Kissingers
Meisterstück wisst ihr es wird oft
angenommen dass die Idee der Annäherung
zwischen den USA und China von Kissinger
stammt aber in Wirklichkeit war dies ein
Spiel das Richard Nixon schon jahrelang
befürwortet hatte noch bevor er ins
Weiße Haus kam seht es euch an
langfristig gesehen können wir es uns
einfach nicht leisten China für immer
außerhalb der Familie der Nationen zu
lassen es gibt keinen Platz auf diesem
kleinen Planeten für eine Milliarde
seiner potenziell fähigsten Menschen die
in wütender Isolation Leben Asia after
Vietnam ein von Richard Nixon in foreign
affairs veröffentlichte Artikel im
Oktober
1967 kissenger und Nixon waren sich über
die Diagnose einig aber die Annäherung
an Peking war alles andere als einfach
was würde aus den gegenüber Taiwan
eingegangenen Verpflichtungen werden wie
nähert man sich einem so verschlossenen
und feinseligen Land an war es wirklich
machbar die Beziehungen zu Maus China zu
stärken nun sagen wir einfach dass
Kissingers Ass im Ärmel wieder einmal
die pendeldiplomatie war als chesku 1969
die USA besuchte bat Nixon ihn
persönlich Maus Regierung wissen zu
lassen dass er Gespräche zwischen den
beiden Regierungen aufnehmen wolle
vergesst bitte nicht dass Washington
damals noch die Republik China das heißt
Taiwan und nicht die Volksrepublik China
als rechtmäßiges China anerkannte
tatsache ist aber dass das Angebot
Washingtons auf taubechinesische Ohren
stieß deshalb B kissenger im folgenden
Jahr den US-Botschafter in Polen dem
ersten chinesischen Diplomaten der ihm
über den Weg laufen würde eine Botschaft
zu übermitteln und nein E-Mails waren
damals noch keine
Option aber eine Gelegenheit bot sich
bald darauf bei einer jugoslawischen
Veranstaltung und so kam es im Dezember
1970 zum ersten offiz ellen Kontakt
zwischen Nixon und dem chinesischen
Premierminister Joe en und dies ebnete
den Weg für kissengers geheime Besuche
im kommmunistischen China im Jahr 1971
während dieser inoffiziellen Treffen
wurden die Bedingungen für die neuen im
Entstehen begriffenen Beziehungen
vereinbart die geheime Reise wurde
arrangiert indem ein Besuch von mir in
Vietnam Thailand Indien und Pakistan
eingeplant wurde in Islamabad wurde eine
Unpässlichkeit bekanntgegeben die meine
anschließende zweitägige Abwesenheit mit
einem Erholungs Aufenthalt in einer
Bergstation erklären sollte der gesamte
Prozess von nens Gespräch mit ychja Khan
am 25 oktober 1970 bis zu meiner Ankunft
in Peking am 9 juli 1971 dauerte 8
Monate Henry Kissinger in seinem Buch
leadership six studies in global
strategy und kurz darauf wurde mit der
Ankündigung von nixens eigenen Besuch in
China eine neue era eingeläutet
requ
tightnce
am 25 oktober 1971 erkannte der
unserheitsrat die Volksrepublik China
endgültig als das wahre China
an allerdings ist es Peking nie gelungen
die USA dazu zu bringen ihre
Verpflichtung gegenüber Taiwan
aufzugeben
im Falle Chinas vertrat gisser den
Standpunkt dass Nationen mit einer
gewissen macht und Feuerkraft nicht am
Rande des internationalen Systems der
Diplomatie und der globalen Ordnung
leben können weil ung destruktives
Verhalten provozieren würde in diesem
Spiel war der Verzicht auf die formelle
Anerkennung Taiwans etwas das sagen wir
mal akzeptabel war es ist die grobe
Definition einer Politik der ihre
Anhänger das Label Realpolitik verpasst
haben eine geopolitische Strategie die
wie Kissinger selbst ebenso viele
Bewunderer wie Gegner hat und deswegen
nehmen wir sie und ihre Auswirkungen nun
ganz genau unter die
Lupe schwarz und etwas
weiß die Abkommen mit der Sowjetunion
die Aussöhnung mit China das Ende des
Vietnamkriegs die Friedensverhandlungen
im Nahen Osten das ist vielleicht die
beste Seite von Kissingers politischenem
Glücksspiel andere Aspekte hingegen
rufen nicht so viel Bewunderung hervor
kissenger zögerte z.B nicht verschiedene
Arten von schmutzigen kriegen und
Diktaturen zu unterstützen um die
Ausbreitung des Kommunismus in
Lateinamerika zu stoppen Henry Kissinger
wird 100 der umstrittene
Friedensnobelpreisträger der den
schmutzigen Krieg unterstützte der
Tausende von Toten in Lateinamerika
forderte das was ihr gleich sehen werdet
ist z.B ein Bekannter Satz den Kissinger
an den argentinischen Admiral Cesar
Augusto gusetti richtete den Kanzler der
militärhunta von Rafael Veda der sich
nur drei Monate zuvor an die Macht
geputscht hatte wenn es Dinge gibt die
getan werden müssen solltet ihr sie
schnell tun aber ihr solltet schnell zu
normalen Abläufen zurückkehren es
scheint ziemlich klar zu sein wovon er
spricht nicht wahr Unterdrückung und
Verfolgung die sogenannte Realpolitik in
reheinultur und in all ihrer
Hässlichkeit äußerst umstritten war auch
seine Politik die massiven
Bombardierungen in Kambodscha und Laos
auszuweiten um den wir Kong zu schwächen
bevor man sich zu Verhandlungen
zusammensetzte die Bombardierung
Kambodschas war Teil von Nixons madman
Theorie mit der er Nordvietnam
einschüchtern und zeigen wollte dass er
ein gefährlicher Führer ist der zu allem
fähig sei da jedoch nur der US-Kongress
einem Land den Krieg erklären kann was
im Rahmen der allgemeinen Stimmung 1969
nicht getan hätte befahen Nixon und
Kissinger die Bombardierungen als
Geheimoperation durchzuführen sie waren
somit Deore illegal es handelte sich
schlicht und einfach um ein
Kriegsverbrechen wenn du einmal in
Kambodscha warst wirst du nie wieder
aufhören Henry Kissinger mit bloßen
Händen erschlagen zu wollen ihr werdet
nie wieder eine Zeitung aufschlagen
können und über diesen verräterischen
lögnerischen mörderischen drecksker
lesen können wie er bei einem netten
Gespräch mit Charlie Rose zusammensitzt
oder einen Gala Abend für ein neues
Hochglanzmagazin besucht ohne kotzen zu
müssen wenn du Zeuge dessen geworden
bist was Henry in kambodcha getan hat
die Früchte seines Genies für
Staatskunst wirst du nie verstehen warum
er nicht neben miloschwiic auf der
Anklagebank in den hach sitzt das
Ergebnis der grausamen Verwüstungen war
ein destabilisiertes Land in dem
schließlich polpots Terrorregime der
roten kmerär an die Macht kommen konnte
eine massenmörderbande der 2 Millionen
Menschen 25 % der Bevölkerung kambodchas
zum Opfer fallen sollten
kissengererschien dies indes nicht im
Geringsten zu
jucken ihr solltet den Kambodschanern
sagen dass wir mit ihnen befreundet sein
werden sie sind mörderische Schurken
aber wir werden uns davon nicht
aufhalten lassen Henry Kissinger im
November 1978 7 Monate nach der
Machtübernahme der roten K und warum na
weil Poul Pot von den Chinesen
unterstützt wurde Kissingers
kuschelkommunisten und weil er zusammen
mit Ihnen ein Feind der für kissenger
minderwertigen Vietnamesen war so tickte
dieser Realpolitiker und trotz alldem
wird der in einer Umfrage unter
amerikanischen Akademikern aus dem Jahr
2015 als der effizienteste Außenminister
der letzten 50 Jahre bezeichnet schaut
es euch
an tja das war wohl das Ergebnis der
vorhin von Professor O'Brien erwähnten
PR Maschinerie und des schönen Labels
Realpolitik das Pragmatismus suggerieren
sollte bei alldem ist jedoch vor allem
eines klar so hart und unbarmherzig
Kissinger gegenüber den kleinen und für
ihn unbedeutenden war so unterwürfig
verhielt er sich gegenüber den großen
und mächtigen selbst wenn es sich dabei
um Tyrannen und Diktatoren handelte dies
fing mit den Sowjets und den Chinesen an
und giipfelte schließlich 2022 nach dem
Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine in
peinlichen bis gefährlichen Appeasement
Appell
25.05.2022 Kissinger schlägt vor dass
die Ukraine Territorium an Russland
abgibt dies rief scharfe Kritik hervor
der ehemalige Außenminister
argumentierte dass die Abtretung von
Land ein Ende des Krieges herbeiführen
könnte Kritiker nannten die Idee
rücksichtslos und unrealistisch wohl
gemerkt Kissinger forderte dies zu einer
Zeit noch bevor die Ukraine herson und
große Teile ihres Territoriums im Osten
befreit hatte er zeigte damit vor allem
dass er einfach nicht in der Lage war
die militärische Stärke sowohl Russlands
als auch der Ukraine realistisch
einzuschätzen ein ähnliches Fehlurteil
hatte er aber bereits 2014 bezüglich der
politisch gesellschaftlichen Struktur in
der Ukraine
abgegeben der Westen spricht Ukrainisch
der Osten spricht hauptsächlich russisch
jeder Versuch eines Flügels der Ukraine
den anderen zu dominieren wie es bisher
der Fall war würde schließlich zu einem
Bürgerkrieg oder zum Auseinanderbrechen
führen tja da konnten wir sie bereits
beobachten die Entzauberung des
realpolitischen Genies Kissinger der die
Mentalität von Menschen und ganzer
Gesellschaften einfach an der Sprache
festmacht die diese sprechen
oberflächlicher und Platter geht es wohl
nicht mehr vor Allem handelt es sich
nicht gerade um ein rohesblatt für
jemanden der sich Realpolitiker nennt
wir haben über den großen Mythos
Realpolitik jedoch bereits ein
ausführliches und entlarfendes Video
hier auf visualpolitik gedreht dass ihr
euch im Anschluss über den Link oben
rechts hinter dem i oder in der
Videobeschreibung ansehen könnt dass
Menschen und Gesellschaften wertebasiert
handeln könnten und hinter ihren
Prinzipien stehen war für ein allglatten
und empathielos Opportunisten wie
kissenger eben ein Konzept wie aus einem
anderen Universum das Problem kissengers
war aber vor allem dass er Schein immer
über sein stellte nicht nur bei sich
selbst sondern eben auch bei jenen
geopolitischen Mächten die realistisch
einzuschätzen und zu bändigen eigentlich
sein Job gewesen wäre so ließ er sich
immer wieder vom aufgeplusterten Macho
gehaber der Russen Blenden ohne ihre
wahre Realität dahinter zu erkennen er
begriff nie dass sie nur die Sprache der
Härte verstehen und Nachgiebigkeit als
Schwäche die es unbedingt auszunutzen
gilt und so lamentiert er fast bis
zuletzt davon dass der Russe oder der
Chinese dies und jenes nie akzeptieren
werde und dass man auf diese
Befindlichkeiten unbedingt Rücksicht
nehmen müsse und zwar auch auf Kosten
anderer Staaten und Völker die in den
Augen Kissingers jedoch zu unbedeutend
waren als dass man ihre Souveränität und
ihre Sicherheitsinteressen ernst nehmen
müsse das war also Kissingers
Realpolitik ein primitives Gesetz des
Stärkeren etwas wogegen wir eigentlich
Strukturen aufgebaut haben die sich
Zivilisation nennen aber zum Glück haben
ihn sowohl die Ukrainer als auch die
Polen und Balten eines Besseren belehrt
denn sieehe da er hat diese Lehren doch
tatsächlich angenommen und änderte
während seines letzten lebensjahres noch
seine Meinung im Januar 2023 sagte
Kissinger schließlich dass die
Unterstützung der Ukraine verstärkt
werden müsse bis die Grenzen vom 24
Februar entweder von ihr zurückerobert
oder durch Russland im Rahmen von
Verhandlungen anerkannt werden ja die
würde immer noch eine Abtretung der Krim
und des Donbass bedeuten aber für
Kissinger immerhin ein Schritt in die
richtige Richtung er vertrat die Ansicht
dass Russland die Möglichkeit gegeben
werden muss sich wieder in die
Weltgemeinschaft einzugliedern WR die
Sanktion aber aufrecht erhalten werden
bis eine endgültige Lösung erreicht ist
Kissinger drückte auch seine Bewunderung
für Präsident zelenski aus und lobte das
htenhafte Verhalten des ukrainischen
Volkes und er gelangte schließlich zu
der Meinung dass die Invasion ipsuo zu
einer natomitgliedschaft der Ukraine am
Ende des Friedensprozesses führen wird
in den Wochen vor seinem Tod äußerte er
sich zudem auch extrem realistisch zum
Terroranschlag der Hamas auf Israel der
offene Akt der Aggression der Hamas muss
mit einer gewissen Strafe beantwortet
werden der naastkonflikt wirgt die
Gefahr zu eskalieren und andere
arabische Länder unter den Druck ihrer
öffentlichen Meinung zu bringen das
eigentliche Ziel der Hamas und ihrer
Unterstützer kann nur sein die arabische
Welt gegen Israel zu mobilisieren und
vom Weg friedlicher Verhandlungen
abzubringen die anhaltende Aggression
Russlands in der Ukraine und der Angriff
der Hamas auf Israel stellen einen
fundamentalen Angriff auf das
internationale System da Henry Kissinger
am 11 Oktober 2023 und er gab auch eine
ziemlich scharfe Analyse zur islamischen
Bedrohung Europas ab die infolge des
hamasangriffs offenbar
wurde dass der Angriff der Hamas auf
Israel auf den Straßen Berlins gefeiert
wird zeigt dass Deutschland zu viele
Ausländer ins Land gelassen hat es war
ein großer Fehler so viele Menschen mit
völlig unterschiedlichen Kulturen
Religionen und Konzepten ins Land zu
lassen denn dadurch entsteht in jedem
Land eine Interessengruppe die so etwas
tut Henry Kissinger am 11 Oktober 2023
es ist auf der einen Seite also
beruhigend dass Menschen auch bis ins
hohe Alter noch lernfähig sind auf der
anderen Seite erscheint es jedoch umso
schlimmer wenn sie dazu so lange
gebraucht haben alles in allem war Henry
Kissinger also ein Mann mit vielen Licht
und Schattenseiten aber unabhängig davon
ob wir diese krude Form der
internationalen Politik die er vertrat
in der alles möglich ist selbst wenn es
bedeutet den schlimmsten Regimes der
Welt in den Allerwertesten zu kriechen
mehr oder weniger bevorworten hat
Kissinger die Welt wie wir sie heute
kennen maßgeblich mitgestaltet und
deswegen würde mich jetzt eure Meinung
zu diesem Mann interessieren was haltet
ihr von Henry Kissingers Vermächtnis was
denkt ihr über sein Engagement für die
sogenannte Realpolitik ist sie nichts
als ein hohes Marketing Label glaubt ihr
dass seine Rolle eher positiv oder eher
negativ war ich bin auf eure Kommentare
zu diesen Kontroversen Menschen schon
mächtig gespannt und hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat ihr vielleicht
dabei auch etwas gelern hab falls ja
gibt ihm bitte ein Like teilt mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert es mit ihnen
natürlich freuen wir uns jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch mit uns dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video in diesem Sinne mach's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald